let's go next to Thomas from Vietnam
what time is it in Vietnam it must be is
it like 2 A.M or something like that I
don't even know what time it is there
Thomas please unmute yourself so you can
tell me what time it is
no boy
Thomas yourself music there you go
hey uh it's almost midnight here it's
almost midnight to uh yeah 10 to 12.
I love it what's going on today
um all right so we've
um it's Joe Biden uh going to join the
race and for the uh election who do you
think is going to be the next
um nominee for the uh
the craft party I believe it will be Joe
Biden
uh yeah but who who who would challenge
uh Joe body on on a primary would be the
most likely uh candidate do you think to
to win or to challenge
uh to challenge Joe Biden on the on the
primary for the Democrats I mean I think
it's the people that are currently
running it's Marianne Williamson and
Bobby Kennedy Jr I it doesn't seem like
there's a big appetite from serious
Democratic contenders to challenge Joe
Biden I don't think we're going to see
that
right but uh do you think who would you
know be postly the biggest challenge to
Joe Biden at the moment oh if they ran
who might really be able to challenge
him in a serious way right yeah yeah
that's what I meant you know there I
have two views on this one view is
another Center left Democrat who's just
younger and more energizing but who
isn't too far left would do best so like
that would be an argument for like Gavin
Newsom if Gavin Newsom challenge Joe
Biden it's someone who's not very far to
Biden's left but he's energized and he
has an approach to dealing with
Republicans that might be more appealing
but on the one on the other hand the
name recognition isn't really fully
there and I don't know the other
perspective is the way to challenge Joe
Biden most effectively would be
balancing being truly on the left as
some Define it and being more well known
so that would point to Someone Like
Bernie Sanders who is even older than
Joe Biden even though people want a
younger person rather than an older
person but but Bernie would be the
person who would be able to eke out the
most support my instinct is If today you
say to me Newsome enters or Bernie
enters I think if Bernie announces today
he immediately picks up more support
than Newsom would against Biden that's
my view right now
not enough to win not enough to win but
more support than you some would get
right personally I would love nibsum
because I love his energy and
hello is his adequence as well and and
his he and he provides the the amount of
tenacity that I think the Democrats
really need to to step up to the uh to
the competition against the uh
uh the Republicans I love newsom's
tenacity I love the way he says we need
to be ruthless and all of those things
right I don't know that he yet has the
name recognition to even have a shot in
Hell against an incumbent president but
in an open Democratic primary could be a
different story
right right okay thank you that's it for
me all right Thomas from Vietnam very
good to hear from you so great to hear
from anyone that called in and also
anyone who called in but wasn't able to
talk to me we will take calls again and
I so look forward to speaking with you
next time we'll take a quick break and
be right back